الكرام المراقبون الامميون في اوكرانيا
وعددهم يفوق مئه مراقب دابوا خلال العام
المنصرم على توفيق جرائم الحرب والجرائم
ضد الانسانيه والخروقات للقانون الانساني
الدولي وحقوق الانسان وذلك بهدف رجع
الجناه من الطرفين
ومحاسبتهم
ويسعدنا الان نستضيف عبر الاثير من كييف
الدبلوماسيه الاستراليه
رئيسه البعثه الدوليه لمراقبي حقوق
الانسان في اوكرانيا
مرحبا بك على قناتي العربيه والحدث شكرا
جزيلا لك طلب
اود ان ابدا بالحديث عن الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه والانتهاكات في اوكرانيا ما هو
اجمالي للاشخاص الذين فقدوا ارواحهم منذ
بدء الحرب وكيف تسجلون اعداد الوفيات
والجرحى في اوكرانيا
لقد قمنا بتسجيل الضحايا بين المدنيين في
اوكرانيا منذ الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
من العام الماضي وقد سجلنا اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف مدنيه
قتلوا اكثر من ثمانيه عشر الف جريحوا
وقمنا بالتسجيل منذ 2014 مع بدء النزاع في
شرق اوكرانيا لكنه تصاعد منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي
بينما تدخل الحرب عمها الثاني هل تعتقدين
ان الجرائم انتهاكات حقوق الانسان سوف
تنخفض او تزداد
صراحه امل انها سوف تنخفض فنحن شهدنا
اعداد كبيره من الناس يموتون لا سيما في
شهور الاولى من العام الماضي في شهر مارس
وشهر ابريل المئات من الاشخاص كانه يموتون
يوميا واحيانا يموتوا المئات في اليوم
الواحد شاهدنا بعض الانخفاض في الضحايا
المدنيين كل يوم
نامل ان ان رصدنا للحالات سوف يسلط الضوء
على هذه القضايا وسوف يضغط على طرفين طرفي
الصراع لاتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه لخفض هذه
الضحايا
تمت مساء بشان ابريل من العام الماضي
بشان اعاده توفير روسيا لحوالي 100 الف
واوكراني من مناطق الحرب وصولا الى
سيبيريا والدائره القطبيه هل هذه التقارير
ذات مصداقيه
نظرنا في هذا الامر
بتفاصيل كثيره لا نعلم حجم هذا النزوح
باتجاه روسيا وكل حاله بحاجه لان ينظر
اليها بدقه حسب ظروفها لان بعض الاشخاص
قرروا الطواعيه الانتقال الى روسيا
وكان ذلك امر مناسب بالنسبه لهم بينما
اخرون اجبروا على النزوح اذا كل حاله
بحاجه لان ننظر اليها من حيث تفاصيلها
لوقوف عما اذا كان هناك انتهاك ام لا
اتهمتم السنه الماضيه الروسيه بمنع الوصول
الى اسرى الحرب وقلت ان اراقبكم لديهم
ادله عن سوء المعامله وتعذيب اسرى الحرب
الاوكرانيه
وهذا قد يشكل جرائم حرب هل تسمح روسيا
الان الوصول كلا روسيا لم تسمح لنا الوصول
الى اسرى الحرب لديها
ولم نتمكن من وصول اليهم سواء كان ذلك في
المناطق المحتله او في الاتحاد الروسي
نفسه
وقمنا بزياره وحيده لاسرى الحرب في
المناطق المحتله لكنها لم تكن سريه لم
نستطيع القيام بمقابلات سريه هناك
ولكن لقد قمنا بتوثيق الانتهاكات في
الجانبين
ولدين
الوصول الى اسرى الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
زرنا اسرى الحرب الروس داخل اوكرانيا كما
قمنا بتوثيق انتهاكات حقوق الانسان مثل
التعذيب وسوء المعامله
بالتاكيد نحتاج للوصول لاسرى الحرب في
روسيا
حتى نتمكن من رصد اوضاعهم وكذلك
نشر
وتوثيق ما يحدث لهم اود ان انتقل الان الى
الجرائم والمحاسبه عملت في منظومه الامم
المتحده منذ عام 2000
في مراكز قياديه في مجال حقوق الانسان في
اسيا الوسطى والمحيط الهادي وجنوبي شرق
اسيا وحتى ليبيا وبيلاروسيا ولديك ادراك
جيد للغه الروسيه على حد علمي وانت الواقع
محاميه
الدفاع اذا سؤالي لك طالما انك في المكان
المناسب هل لك تلخص لنا
الجرائم التي ارتكبها الجانبان في هذه
الحرب
الولايات تتهم روسيا الان على نيه بان
ارتكبت جرائم ضد الانساني
لقد قمنا بتوثيق انتهاكات خطيره
لقانون حقوق الانسان الدولي وكذلك انتهت
خطيره للقانون الانساني الدولي وهذه هي
الانتهاكات ترتقي او بعضها يرتقي لجرائم
حرب
وبالتالي فان انواع الجرائم التي قمنا
بتوثيقها كانت التعذيب وسوء المعامله
وكذلك الاعدام دون محاكمه
عاديه وكذلك
المعاملات المدنيين حيث قتل المدنيين في
مناطق
الصراع والجانبه التي توخان الحذر الكافي
لضمان ان الاعمال عدائيه لن تؤثر على
المدنيين حولهم ولكن هل ترتقي هذه الفئات
الجرائم الاربعه
والمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تختص بهذه
المسائل مثل الجرائم ضد الانسانيه وجرائم
الحرب وكذلك جرائم بعد جماعيه والجرائم
العدوانيه هل وصلت الانتهاكات الى هذه
المستويات
بالتاكيد هي وصلت الى مستوى جرائم حرب اما
بالنسبه لجرائم ضد الانسانيه هذا يحتاج
لمحكمه تنظر في المسؤوليات الفرديه وعلى
المحكمه ان تقرر بالكثير من التفاصيل
المسؤوليه الجنائيه لاي فرض فيما يتعلق
بهذه
الجرائم اما بالنسبه
للجرائم ضد الانسانيه تشمل جرائم الحرب
ولكن ليس ذلك فقط هذا يتطلب
اعطاء دليل بان هناك استهداف للمدنيين
واقعيا
هل سوف نشهد تحقيق العداله على الاطلاق
لاولئك الذين يجب ان يحاسبوا على هذه
الجرائم من المنظور الواقعي طبعا
لقد شهدنا عددا من القضايا
حكم فيها
افراد حيث هناك من وجد مذنبا في جرائم
الحرب بهذا المستوى المستوى الوطني سوف
نشهد بعض المحاسبه
اما بالنسبه
المستويات العليا من حيث المسؤوليه الامر
يكون اكثر صعوبه ويحتاج الى وقت اطول ولكن
عليه نواصل التوثيق لان هذا سيساعد كثيرا
في القضايا التي تنظر فيها المحاكم
بالنسبه لعملك وفريقك ما هي العراقيل
الكبرى التي تواجهونها في القيام بالتفويض
الممنوح لكم هل هي السلامه ام الوصول
الواقع الامر يتعلق بهذين الجانبين الذين
اشرت اليهما
فهناك اماكن بها الكثير من العمليات
الادعيه ولا نستطيع الوصول اليها ولكن هذا
لا يعني ان او هذا يعني ان يصعب علينا رصد
اوضاع المدنيين القريبين من خطوط المواجهه
نقوم رغم ذلك بالرصد عن بعد ولكن الامر
يكون صعبا للغايه فهذا ينطبق ايضا على
الوصول لم نحصل على المزيد من الوصول الى
المناطق المحتله في اوكرانيا وليس لدينا
ايضا وصول في روسيا الاتحاديه بالنسبه
للناجح الاوكرانيين او اسرى الحرب
كيف تحصلون انت وفريقك على المعلومات كيف
تحددون من هو المسؤول عن الجرائم
والانتهاكات ما مدى صعوبه ذلك
مصادر معلومات الاساسيه التي نعول عليها
هي ارباحهم والضحايا والشهود حيث نزول
المجتمعات التي حدثت فيها هذه الانتهاكات
ونتحدث للاشخاص المتضررين مباشره
وندون ملاحظاتهم نتحدث الى اكبر عدد ممكن
من الاشخاص ثم نحقق في الامر وندقق ننظر
في الوثائق الرسميه وكذلك الصور
والفيديوهات واي اننا نستخدم كل ما
استطعنا من معلومات ثم نقوم بالتحقق من
ذلك وننظر فيما اذا كان معقولنا نعتقد ان
الانتهاك قد وقع ام لا هذه المعلومات التي
تجمعونها وتوثقونها ماذا تقومون بها هل
يتم تسليمها الى هيئات اخرى ام انها او ان
هذا سيتم في نهايه الحرب عندما تهدا
الامور
لدينا قاعده بيانات امنه يتم حفظ
المعلومات فيها بطريقه سليمه وتكون متاحه
الان وفي المستقبل ايضا
ونقوم ايضا بنشر تقارير بشكل دوري
ننشر تقارير اربع مرات في السنه ترفع الى
مجلس حقوق الانسان وهناك تقارير اخرى ترفع
الامين العام بشان الوضع في شبه جزيره
القرمو ننشر ايضا بعض التقارير الاحاطيه
الكثير من التقارير تعول على معلومات تكون
علنيه ولكننا ايضا نتعاون مع الحكومات
وكذلك المنظمات الاقليميه والطراف اخرى
ذات صله بوضع حقوق الانسان في اوكرانيا
ونتقاسم المعلومات مباشره معهم
هذه المعلومات التي تجمعونها وتوثقونها هل
سوف تستخدم في يوم من الايام
في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
او ان
ترفع الى محكمه خاصه يتم انشاؤها للنظر في
الجرائم التي ارتكبت في اوكرانيا كانت في
اوكرانيا وخارجها معلومات استخدمتها
المحاكم الدوليه واستخدامتها محكمه العدل
الدوليه وكذلك
محكمه حقوق الانسان الاوروبيه وغيرهما اذا
نحن نعتقد انه من الاهميه بما كان ان يتم
استخدام المعلومات التي نجمعها
المحكمه الجنائي الدوليه موجوده في
اوكرانيا وهي تحقق في حالات بعينها ونتوقع
انها سوف تحاكم الاشخاص ادركنا الوقت لدي
سؤال اخير
للمراقبين الذين يتجاوز عددهم مئه مراقب
يعملون الان في اوكرانيا
كيف تتعاملون انتم مع فضائع الجرائم التي
تشهدونها وتوثقونها كيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الجانب من العمل
الامر صعب
للمراقبين الذين يقومون بشكل يومي بهذا
العمل نحن نوثق على سبيل المثال قتل
المدنيين وبعض الاعدامات هذا صعب بالنسبه
للمراقبين وبالنسبه لي ايضا عندما اسمع عن
هذه القصص ولكن نحن ندرك ان هذا الجزء
يتجزا من العمل الرامي الى تحقيق العداله
للضحايا وكذلك اصر الضحايا واعتقد هذا
يساعدنا على العمل ومواصلته نتيجه
بعثه الامم المتحده لرصد حقوق الانسان في
اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك على اعمالك وعلى
الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان في اوكرانيا وفي
اي مكان اخر في العالم اتمنى لك
التوفيق
ورافقه السلامه
شكرا جزيلا لك طلال على هذه الاستضافه
الكريمه شكرا لك
شكرا لكم في دبي ونترك لكم الكلمه الان
[موسيقى]